revenons maintenant sur cette info
donnée hier par la mairie de paris et
qui provoque un certain nombre de
réactions parfois positive parfois
négative le stationnement va devenir
payant pour les deux roues à essence à
partir de 2022 ce sera 3 euros de
l'heure pour les voitures ça passera
d'ailleurs à 6 euros par endroits dans
la capitale 6 euros de l'heure
avant d'en parler avec vous en plateau
on va accueillir dans ce match des idées
david belliard bonsoir vous êtes adjoint
à la mairie de paris en charge de la
transformation de l'espace public et
merci beaucoup d'intervenir dans ce
match des idées vous l'avez entendu
j'imagine cette colère des conducteurs
de deux roues les motards notamment qu'
au parle carrément de raquette vous vous
y attendiez j'imagine aussi qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez leur dire pour apaiser
cette tension
d'abord il ya pas de raquette ce qu'on
est en train de faire c'est que nous
rétablissons d'une certaine manière une
forme d'injustice puisque jusqu'à
maintenant les automobilistes paient une
contribution à usages de l'espace public
alors que les propriétaires et les
utilisateurs de deux roues motorisés les
motos les les scooters et bien ne n'en
payez pas puisqu'il y avait la gratuité
c'est un régime d'exemption à laquelle
nous mettons fin et nous mettons fin
d'abord parce que c'est encore une fois
une question d'équité entre les
utilisateurs de l'espace public et puis
c'est aussi une question plus large une
logique plus globale lorsque vous
utilisez à deux roues motorisés et vous
fait beaucoup de bruit beaucoup de
nuisances sonores et c'est
particulièrement vrai aujourd'hui un lot
de laits parisiennes et parisiens sont
habitués avec la crise sanitaire que
nous vivons est bien à une ville qui est
une ville un peu plus apaisé et sont
beaucoup plus sensibles à la question du
bruit
et puis il ya aussi les questions de
pollution de pollution de l'air et il
est normal juste d'une certaine manière
que celles et ceux qui produisent ces
nuisances et bien participent compense
d'une certaine manière avec un un
paiement de l'usaj de l'espace public
pour permettre à la collectivité qu'est
paris investir dans la transition écolo
de pouvoir avoir des investissements
d'aménagement puisque par exemple nous
avons proposé avec cette réforme bien la
création de 5000 nouvelles places pour
les deux roues motorisés tout ça ce sont
des coûts et il me semble de bonne
gestion et de bonne jeu
6 2 permettre de favoriser en tout cas
la contribution de ses usagers à
l'effort collectif
mais lire on apprend aussi même si je me
trompe pas que le stationnement va
devenir payant dans les bois de
vincennes et les bois de boulogne 4
euros de l'heure à partir de l'automne
prochain si je ne me trompe pas que
dites-vous là cette fois aux familles
qui aux familles de banlieue qui
viennent de banlieue qui viennent faire
qu'ils venaient faire des pique-niques
c'est fini non sur ce samedi le samedi
où on sera un euro 60 de leurs pour
permettre un usage du bois familiale
justement et le dimanche reste reste
gratuit pour être parfaitement complet
là encore dans les bois on a des
problèmes d'encombrement on a des
problèmes d'abus de places qui sont
effectivement déplace aujourd'hui
gratuité qui ne sont pas utilisés par
des gens qui vont au bois et nous avons
aujourd'hui besoin que ce soit à
vincennes ou à boulogne vient de mieux
réguler encore une fois c'est un outil
de régulation et moi je le dis aussi
notre volonté c'est de favoriser
d'inciter à l' usage d'autres mobilité
que celle de la voiture individuelle
utiliser les transports en commun s'est
déjà d'ailleurs le cas massivement
puisque j'entends beaucoup de choses sur
les réseaux sociaux beaucoup de choses
dans les médias mais il faut se rappeler
toujours d'un chiffre 80 % des
déplacements banlieue paris paris
banlieue sont d'abord faites par les
transports en commun et sur les 20% qui
reste bien il y a énormément de trafic
lié aux mobilités dix professionnels et
ses professionnels là je pense notamment
aux commerçants et aux artisans
bénéficie grâce à une carte qui
s'appelle pro mobile est bien de tarifs
extrêmement attractifs ces 50 centimes
de l'heure mais vous êtes d'accord avec
moi david belliard et après évidemment
on en discutera en plateau que les
transports en commun ne soient
accessibles que lorsque vous avez tout
votre motricité que vous n'avez pas de
poussettes que vous n'avez aucun
handicap
ça veut dire que certains endroits de
paris ne seront plus accessibles à ces
gens là non non parce que nous
travaillons justement sur les questions
d'accessibilité alors un autre
à faire je le sais je le concède sur les
transports en commun et là-dessus
j'entendais votre invité tout à leur
parler du bilan de valérie pécresse
belleville ans valérie pecresse c'est le
fait qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons que 4 5
% des stations de métro à paris et et
plus largement que en métropole de grand
paris qui ne sont pas accessibles mais
plus juste sur la question permettez moi
du handicap
nous allons créer mille places
supplémentaires aujourd'hui réservées
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
ces places pmr
nous aurons à peu prés 5800 places à
terme à paris et évidemment ce
stationnement
ce stationnement il reste payant et il
sera étendu progressivement cette
gratuité sera étendu progressivement au
stationnement en sous-sol pour justement
permettre par exemple aux personnes en
situation de handicap de pouvoir
circuler et pour voir se déplacer parce
que effectivement la mobilité doit être
un droit accessible à toutes et à tous
alors si vous le permettez on va
évidemment discuter de tout ce que vous
avez dit sur ce plateau et je vous
laisserai réagir si vous le souhaiter
évidemment corentin le fur mais bon sur
le sur le times a elle-même pécresse me
suis pas représenté mme pécresse
les électeurs auront l'occasion de
trancher dans très peu de temps donc on
va passer à la suite sur le sur les
annonces il ya deux choses en fait moi
je fais une différence entre
la réglementation sur les deux roues
motorisés et l'autre aspect qui est
l'augmentation des tarifs visiteurs pour
les voitures à partir du mois d'août sur
le premier aspect effectivement c'est
pas l'élément qui me semble le plus
choquant à la base les deux roues en
plus ont la possibilité de se garer
si je ne m'abuse y compris sur des
places préserver initialement des
voitures dont il ya un principe d'équité
pourquoi des automobilistes perret et
palais de rohan soit c'est pas le
principe qui me semble plus j'en aurais
pu faire ça dans le sens inverse mais
préfère payer personne
oui mais ça savez je pense que peut-être
que la mairie de paris a besoin d'argent
oui peut-être mais simple non la
question derrière c'est surtout la
question justement de l'augmentation des
tarifs dits visiteurs côté voitures
inciter aux mobilités douces moi je suis
le premier je prends les transports en
commun donc a pas de souci là-dessus
le seul problème c'est qu'on sait très
bien qu'avec cette logique est toujours
un peu la même d'écologie très punitive
très taxe hâtive ont fait quelque part
une certaine discrimination puisque les
6 euros par heure pour les quartiers les
plus centraux de paris
évidemment que tout le monde ne veut pas
se les payer et qu'il ya certaines
personnes et pas que des oeufs sur des
aspects professionnels qui ne l'ont pas
d'autre possibilité d'utiliser leur
voiture
c'est la même logique que les
restrictions à l'intérieur du périmètre
de l'a86 on décrète qu'en fait on va
supprimer les problèmes où on va faire
de nouvelles incitations comportementale
juste avec quelque part détails puisque
c'est assumé avec ce tarif le
stationnement en parking souterrain va
devenir quasiment plus intéressant
financièrement que en surface
donc le problème c'est que on crée une
taxe non résoudra de toute façon pas le
problème puisque si on ne va pas
derrière avec un minimum d'incitation
pour les foyers les plus modestes ça
devrais je dire et sensibiliser la
mairie de paris actuellement par les
gens ne le verront que côté taxes et ils
continueront ils prendront le risque ils
fraudent rond
et on qu ils ne viendront plus ils
viendront absolument plus et on
al'impression vraiment que paris se
referme de plus en plus surtout les
banlieusards qui sont de plus en plus
expulser par et d'être maire d'une autre
mais justement j'ai envie de dire enfin
d'abord je pense que je partage tout à
fait ce que dit david lire sur la
nécessité aujourd'hui dans paris de
diminuer absolument la pollution sonore
évidemment la pollution de l'air qui est
un énorme problème de santé publique
invisible mais qui est un énorme
problème qui écoute et qui coûtent des
chaînes sait combien à la sécurité
sociale qui met aussi qui voilà qui tue
dans la pollution de l'air aujourd'hui
tu me voilà donc c'est un énorme
problème à prendre en charge et oui il
faut faire diminuer j'espère qu'on est
d'accord là dessus il faut faire il faut
absolument diminuer le trafic automobile
dans paris et plus largement dans l'île
de placer solange et isme alors une fois
qu'on a dit ça effectivement ça veut
dire que pour pas avoir une écologie
punitive qui lie l alternative et
notamment pour les plus modestes
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut mettre le
paquet sur les transports en commun
notamment banlieue banlieue on en
parlait tout à l'heure dans la moi je
suis à montrer si je veux aller à saint
denis qui est quand même pas loin à 20
minutes en voiture ou en transports en
commun une forme entre 1h et 1h30 bon
blain par en général c'est blindé alors
voilà et qui avec une poussette pour
l'avoir fait il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça c'est l'enfer voilà donc ça veut
dire est qu effectué en qu'il faut
mettre le paquet et justement on en
revient à notre premier sujet ben c'est
exactement là dessus que la gauche et
l'écologie veut veulent agir au niveau
régional exactement lorsque là pour le
coup on est sur les compétences du
conseil régional et de ce point de vue
là il me semble pas que dans les
dernières années et sous valérie
pécresse ait eu un changement absolument
édifiant excusez moi là dessus un mais
je ne crois pas et je crois à mon avis
que les phrases mais la question c'est
est-ce que ces mesures arrivent trop tôt
alors avant qu'on ait mis au point des
transports va la voir ce qu'il faut
faire les deux en même temps donc
effectivement mais il faut il faut quand
même prendre les deux bouts à mon avis
et la deuxième chose
et tant mieux si les recettes de 2,7
voilà deux les recettes les nouvelles
recettes publiques permettent ça il faut
aussi notamment permettre l'accès par
exemple aux vélos et aux vélos
électriques mois mois utilisant aussi le
vélo
dans paris je peux vous dire qu'il
manque encore de la sécurité pour les
vélos mais il manque aussi la leçon par
exemple au vélo et oui tout à fait et il
manque aussi l'accès aux vélos
électriques par exemple 1 et donc ça il
faut des mesures sur les familles les
plus modestes il faut tout un tas
d'aménagement pour pouvoir garer ses
vélos puis voilà donc il ya
effectivement beaucoup à faire sur les
alternatives mais pour moi il faut
prendre les deux bouées et je pense que
du coup ça ça va dans le bon sens à
condition effectivement qu'on est aussi
à la tête du conseil régional et bien
des dirigeants qui qui justement mettre
le paquet là dessus et à condition de ne
pas braquer la population david belliard
où vous ne prenez pas le risque que ce
soit contre productif et que finalement
au lieu d'emmener avec vous un certain
nombre de personnes voulaient braquer
mais d'abord aujourd'hui ce que je suis
en train de vous présenter nous l'avions
proposé pendant la campagne des
municipales était tête de liste
écologiste anne hidalgo était tête de
liste
paris en commun nous avons fusionné ça
fait partie de notre projet le projet
municipal on a on fait ce que nous avons
dit nous disons ce que nous avons fait
ce que nous disent nous avons dit ce que
nous allons faire et nous faisons
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons dit on les
chaussons en grande transparence et les
gens ont voté pour nous là aussi en
toute transparence ce que nous faisons
c'est effectivement une nous sommes dans
une logique qui est une logique de
transformation et je partage
complètement ce qui vient d'être
dernière d'être dire on a des enjeux qui
sont des enjeux majeurs en termes de
dérèglement climatique en termes de
pollution de l'air de santé de santé
publique c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour
laquelle nous ne souhaitons pas la
gratuité parce que ce n'est pas qu'une
question financière quand vous utilisez
votre voiture quand vous utilisez à deux
roues que la déroute ermite parce que je
rappelle que l'électrique restera
gratuit lorsque vous utilisez ce type
d'engin et bien il ya ce qu'on appelle
en économie des externalités négatives
ces externalités négatives
ce sont des coups que nous subissons
tout et tous ceux des coudes pour notre
santé pour le coût pour notre qualité de
vie
les coûts aussi pour la collectivité et
bien c'est quoi ils doivent être en
partie du moins compensée par les
usagers de ces de ses véhicules et je
trouve que aujourd'hui c'est une logique
tête une logique de à la fois de bonne
gestion et et équité et encore une fois
enfin vous avez parfaitement raison
ça ne peut pas
être l'alpha et l'oméga ces questions de
grille tarifaire d'une politique de
transformation
il faut investir dans les transports en
commun et ça c'est la région qui doit
aujourd'hui le faire c'est sa
responsabilité c'est d'ailleurs un des
enjeux majeurs du choix qu'il y aura à
faire dimanche prochain et puis il faut
aussi investir dans les alternatives les
alternatives nous le faisons je suis
parfaitement d'accord nous avons fait un
grand pas sur la question ou en tout cas
un grand coup de peut être sur la
question du vélo à paris il nous faut
encore progresser je suis moi-même
utilisateurs de vélo et je vois à quel
point les continuité cyclable ne sont
pas encore optimales parfois c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
et il nous faut investir et ça ce sont
des investissements de plusieurs
dizaines voire de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros
il faut tout faire d'un coup transports
en commun alternative est aussi
incitation au des incitations
financières à l'usagé de la voiture
individuelle et on s'arrêtera là désolé
le chrono à temps de son livre je
voudrais pas l'occasion de répondre à ce
qu'il vient de dire en tout cas merci
infiniment à tous d'avoir participé à ce
match des idées fin de cette émission
demain à ma place ce sera alexandre
poussard à 22h30 moi je vous retrouve
dimanche dès 22 heures aux côtés de
brigitte boucher pour une édition
spéciale de deux heures autour du
premier tour des élections régionales et
départementales sur les chaînes
parlementaires de m bonjour chez vous et
cette fois ce sera steve jourdain qui
recevra frédéric péchenard tête de liste
lr à paris pour les régionales en île de
france souhaite une excellente soirée
sur public sénat